e aí pessoal hoje vou ensinar como fazer
umas naipe que dispara 3 elastix é eu
tive vários comentários preciso dizer
quem faz outras na época a empresa a
idéia é não fazer outro sinal importante
ser maior
tem que parar mais elásticos e ii tem
que ter aquela coisa ali à frente para
vocês apoiarem no chão como snap
fruteira que a equipe lutou bastante né
na estabilização da arma e por vocês
fazerem esta coisa usar de folhas a4
estou usados impressora mas vocês podem
usar outras folhas quaisquer que é
importante que seja tamanho a4
além disso a ansiedade de ficar e vou
usar que transparente e cola e nesses
casos podem usar uma cola qualquer
no último vídeo aqui que só cola quente
porque tem algumas partes um pouco
difícil fazer com uma cola convencional
é porque os convencionais demoram pneus
caro
imaginem vocês fazer um dois tubinhos
tem claro desta maneira
aí eu vou ensinar como enrolar o papel
que muitas pessoas têm deixado os
comentários de itacibá eu vou fazer é
tão brevemente custa nada é muito legal
bem pequenininho
acho que vocês deixam 3 120 stover
distância pelos quadrinhos letras do que
isso só contra os quatro times já se
distancia da coisa que dá mesmo jeito de
ver os meus dias verde é mais ou menos
visto depois quando eu ia ver não era
bem aquilo então comprei isso ajuda
bastante mas não que é só carregar na
interseção que vai tudo naturalmente
abrir e tem por aqui bastante cola tempo
naquela partida fazendo o curso
inicialmente foi bastante porque ele
quer ficar encaixadas elásticos
depois de ajustar bem tem por coloque em
cima
convém pôr bastante coloque aí pra ficar
resistente que vai vai ficar
posicionados e lá se vão ficar
posicionados elásticas então
bastaram-lhe concentrada alguma atenção
e no final foi um fita porque ajuda
bastante na desistência pode parecer que
não mas ajuda mesmo e para fazer aquela
parte de ver lá é vocês levam a lifan
que vocês usaram inicialmente que eu vou
ensinar a fazer depois
depois é só cortar em pedacinhos e colar
na inter
qualquer bem lá mas nessa e3 certeza
absoluta em todos os lados nem trouxe
vocês fizerem as medidas que eu e agora
fazer a parte da crônica é bastante
simples é só vocês fazem depois mais
duas rifas e dará forma é só ajustar bem
simples cortar pois com fita aprender
tudo acontecer eu vou pôr a para além do
forte
vocês podem bastante cola também caem
enquanto na escola vocês fizerem melhor
votar não vai aguentar mais tempo então
é uma coisa sempre dar uma reforçada com
fita fica sempre bem este hotel tem mais
ou menos 10 por 10 cêntimos não é muito
importante também deu essa pra fazer uma
coisa pequenina e é para pôr aquilo é
que ela foi na frente porque não sei
como é que chama bastante simples fazer
é só encaixar uma rifa na outra e tem
que optar bastante nesta parte aqui
isso ajuda bastante depois porque se
ficar tipo atenção ficar tenso entre
estas duas partes é que vocês vão
conseguir o cheiro deixam e fica naquela
posição agora se tiver folgado é vocês
quando vão por uma posição de direito a
arma não vai ficar porque está folgado
também cai para os lados então perdem
bastante nessa parte ainda está para
pessoas acham que antes entre linha do
meio e extremidade da folha no final é
só aqui encaixar com fita veja como eu
faço por impor-se no primeiro na parte
de cima e depois vou deslizando e aí que
encaixa tudo perfeitinho conhecer fazer
agora a partir da ótica bastante
opcional aconselha a quem podem elaborar
mais conhece bem de frente e nunca puxei
muito neurótica desta vez não tem mais
nada ficou mais bonita é porque tenho
certeza que vocês vão fazer ao vosso
gosto então não vale a pena aqui perder
tempo com essa coisa vai junto e eu vou
usar aquela coisa que fiz anteriormente
para segurar a ótica
acho que sou polêmico das fitas e fica
mais ou menos essa distância que vai
ficar por cima
não ponho muita fita assim pra baixo
pois aí fica muito por cima
op então não vai ficar assim tão bem e
depois é só ajustar o tamanho do bolo
para dentro
depois é só colar encaixar modo fica
presa a outra parte da garrafa
mas nesta partida não vou por força aí
vocês vão ver por quê
mas fita para ficar tudo como é ser
forçado a isso não sei o que dizer
basicamente eu fiz aqui os 3 corte
importante vocês verem inclinação dele
aqui estão inclinados e do modo está
entre os meus corte é de 0,5 e vejam que
na parte da frente que tem muita cola
porque é lá que eu vou encaixar os 3
elásticos e fazer mais uma coisinha
daquela deixar aquela distância
pequenina e isso é para fazer o
objectivo que vocês vão ver que encaixe
naquela para que não vocês não puseram
não fizeram a coisa aqui tem que durar
90 graus
tem que fazer o a mesma coisa pois dois
lados ajam com fita encaixam com fita
ele está a ficar muito bom
encaixam com fita aprendam com fita e
faz com que o corpo inclinado que ajuda
bastante a tirar os elásticos
veja onde cortam tragicamente é do
tamanho daquela primeira fitinha branca
que ela tira branca e em caixa uma vez
que vejo aqui em casa naquela partida em
que não era por força aí foi por isso
que não pôde utilizá la para dentro
então fica um objectivo bastante fixa
até aquela coisa ali para assegurar a
frente encaixa no youtube no baixo e
agora só quer jogar vocês começam a
carga do mais longe para o mais perto e
como é óbvio os primeiros e látex a
encomenda de força em comparação com o
uso de macaé mas como só tem três
elásticos três tipos saem com muita
força neste caso vejam aqui é só puxar e
pronto já está pronta e preparada e já
está pronto para a imagem da contusão
mas só chegamos ao fim os perto do
estado se você tiver alguma sugestão do
projeto é só deixar nos comentários é
inspirado em ajudar o canal deixar um
laico o tui isso escreva como nas coisas
que eu faço lá 7 a 1